[موسيقى]
المهرجان والمشاركه فيه انا اعتقد انها
مش مش استفاده شخصيه فقط لكن هو الحقيقه
فعاليات الفن
المختلفه والتجمع والتعرف بيفيدك كمان في
شغلك متفرج بيحب الكوميدي اكتر انا بعتقد
ده
وخاصه في عالمنا العربي اكتر يعني ان
الكوميديا واخده حيز من اهتمام الناس لانه
بيدوروا عليها وممكن يدفعوا فيها فلوس
كتيره جدا علشان يجدوا الابتسامه يجدوا
الضحكه والحقيقه
السلعه الرائجه او الاكثر ربحا في الفن هي
الكوميديا لكن لو هتديها كوميديا كوميديا
كوميديا المتفرج بعد كده هينصر عندك لانه
في الاخر هيحتاج برض لجرعه رومانسيه لجرعه
اكشن لجرعه ابهار خيال علمي حاجات زي كده
تخرجه تخرجه من المشاعر بتاعته لكن في
النهايه برض هيرجع يصب عند الضحك بنسبه
للاوضاع السياسيه انا اعتقد ان احنا
اصبحنا دلوقتي في حاله يعني استقرار ال حد
كبير بس بنواجه حرب جامده جدا حرب خارجيه
وحرب داخليه لان طبعا اي نظام هيبقى موجود
هجد مؤيد وهيج معارض المعارض عايز يعني
يمشي هذا النظام وعايز ينتقم وعايز يترد
له مكانته تاني المؤيد عايز هذا النظام
يبقى موجود
وصراع سياسي موجود وعايشين
ا اعتقد ممكن هذا الصراع يقل مع حته
الرخاء حته ان يبقى فيه دخل كويس للمواطن
يبقى في فرص عمل كويسه هو ده اللي لازم
البلد يعني تفكر فيه الفتره اللي جايه ديت
النهارده الحق يتقال للسياسه الحاليه
مدركه اهميه الاعلام والثقافه والفن في
بناء الشعوب وانا اعتقد ان دي خطوه كويسه
جدا جدا ان ان القياده السياسيه مهتميه
بالجزء ده الفتره اللي انا يعني بعتبر
انها من اصعب الفترات الفتره اللي فاتت دي
بالظبط انا متفائل جدا باللي جاي اعتقد ان
ده يعني يعني ممكن نشوف حاله من حالات
الاستقرار ان شاء الله قادمه على مصر لما
تيجي تشوفي ان السينما المصريه على مدار
السنه اللي فاتت فقط بعد ثوره
30/6 انا اعتقد ان وما قبلها بشويه اعتقد
ان مافيش فيلم خسر لان الناس كلها كانت
عايزه تخرج كانت عايزه تنطلق عشنا فترات
ا فيها حظر تجول فيها ناس اتقفل عليها باب
ومعرفوش يخرجوا فيها خوف من النزول الشارع
لان في قلق وفي عدم استقرار امني وفي في
خوف كبير النهارده الناس لما بدات تحس ان
بدا
الاستقرار يبقى موجود وابتدى الامن يستتب
والناس تحب تحب يعني انها تخرج وكده ان
خرجوا كلهم راحوا السينما ايا كان الافلام
اللي موجوده هل على مستوى عالي ولا مستوى
مش عالي كلها نجحت بعد
الثورات بيحصل دايما ا حاجه كده بعدم
توازن بتحصل في الفن وخاصه في السينما
بعد الحروب بعد الازمات بعد الثورات بعد
الاحداث اللي هي بتبقى مؤثره جدا في تاريخ
الشعوب بتلاقي السينما دايما بتتاثر مش
بتتاثر انها بيحصل لها نقله فنيه عظيمه لا
بتتاثر بالعكس وانا مش عارف ايه السر في
ده يعني لكن انا اعتقد اعتقد ان السينما
المصريه في الفتره اللي فاتت قدمت نوعيه
افلام كتيره
جدا يعني يعني منها افلام نجحت نجاح كبير
جدا ومنها افلام الجمهور انصرف عنها تماما
ودي علامه كويسه ان الجمهور اصبح ما مش ما
بيضحكش عليه في ادوار انا عملتها انا مش
راضي عنها وكانت في بدايه حياتي
ما يعني ما بحبهاش او حتى ما بحبش اتفرج
عليها يعني لاني كنت مجبر على اني اقدمها
في فتره من الفترات لاني عايز انتشر وعايز
اثبت وجودي وعايز اقول ان هاني رمزي موجود
وانه عنده مواهب او عنده موهبه او حاجه زي
كده في ادوار ثانيه
ا انا فخور بيه جدا ا حببها جدا قدمتها
وخاصه في الفتره الاخيره ا بقول ان اي حتى
عمل بدخله جديد بقول يا رب يعجب الناس يا
رب
يبقى اللي انا حبيته الناس تحبه لكن حته
خطوط حمراء المفترض المفترض ان ما يبقاش
في خطوط حمرا في الفن ان الفن يبقى فيه
ابداع
في حاله
من الكريتيف في في حاجه ان ما ينفعش ان
احنا نحط خط احمر يلجم الفنان ما ينفعش
انا كل هدف الفتره الجايه ان انا اسعد
الناس ان انا فعلا انا عارف قد ايه العالم
العربي والربيع العربي اللي عدى ده ساب
اثار حزينه جوه نفوس الناس من عنف ودم
ومظاهرات واعتصامات
وحظر تجول وعدم استقرار
وانفلات امني وحاجات كتيره جدا كل الحاجات
دي ثابت اثار عند المتفرج او عند الشعب
العربي بشكل كبير جدا لان اي دوله عربيه
حصل فيها حاجه الدول الثانيه بتتاثر بيها
نفوسنا كلها بتتاثر لان احنا كلنا مسمعين
عند بعض كلنا متاثرين ببعض فانا اعتقد ان
الفتره اللي جايه كل طموحي اني اسعد الناس
ادحك الناس من خلال اي عمل كوميدي وانا
شايف ان ده عمل قومي ووطني لو انا قدرت
ارسم ابتسامه على وشوش
الناس